you're from st. Louis and you had a very
normal you know there there I like this
this aspect of your life there are
people that come out here really early
and they only grow up knowing the life
of being in television or working in
this business
you're from st. Louis - in pretty normal
childhood and you worked a lot of normal
jobs I did no I had my first job when I
was 15 I worked in a kennel by my house
and my mom and dad had to drive me there
and my mom and dad are here they're here
I work out to your mom and dad dude do
they want to be identified oh there they
are
gonna get my question is why are they
here every night there's a been waiting
yeah I'm gonna be on they were here on
Monday - I remember that
yeah go see Ellen she's on the lot too
just go you know you and you you worked
fast food chain to it so after the
kennel job but when I could drive myself
I got a job at Long John Silver's oh my
god yes it worked out in the front
taking the orders but I found out that
the people who worked in the back who
were cooking they made 70 cents more per
hour so I went to my manager and I saw
that I would like to learn
I'd like to train to be one of the cooks
and the manager said I'm sorry girls
have to stay up front to greet the
customers with a smile and I said have
you heard of a little thing called
discrimination and you're very young at
this time I make 16 and he was like oh
just combination is good and so I got
trained to work the fryers and I did it
and I fried hush puppies and I know this
is not a spoiler that a lot of the food
at Long John Silver's is fried the
milkshakes at Long John Silver's are
fried everything is fried I think the
cooking is basically being over a hot
bat of oil for like a nine-hour shift
and I was burning my hands and it was
really stinky and the only thing that we
didn't fry was a shrimp scampi that was
a saute but no one ordered the shrimp
scampi right and so after a while I went
to my manager and I said I made a huge
mistake
I I really need to go back out front
oh wait from the fryer and he was like
really someone wanted to fry so bad but
suddenly that was the length of your
vote for your struggle for equality the
minutes to much yes smelling too much
fatty oil and you were like no no that's
okay I'll try okay
but but I do feel like I broke down
barriers
I think you did
[Applause]
you